Thomas's comic came in from one of our
viewers and we were curious how you
would respond guys I'm so scared there
are a certain amount of movies I want to
create and I figured the best route to
start would be with screenwriting but I
just wish I had a guide or something for
the journey seems like people really
spend years doing so much work and only
have results after maybe a decade I'm
not sure if I want to be a screenwriter
but I do know that I have movies I want
to make
help what advice can y'all give me
well I think that
I don't want to ever be discouraging to
somebody who's interested in film but I
think it does take us um
a special kind of determination
to sustain you know like we have
people who of course struck gold
immediately with a movie or script or
whatever and but that's not normal most
most of us
that are working in uh in Los Angeles
have put in 10 years before something
even remotely like real like concrete
happens as far as making your own movie
or editing even a a film that where
you're the lead editor or something like
that you know what I mean like it is a
climb
uh and but I it in that sense though I
don't know if that's
untrue for any other industry either I
think that there's just maybe this
um
sense of La La Land kind of for lack of
better term where you're like yeah of
course we all want to do this I we all
have ideas in movies and and things that
we want to do but if somebody isn't
willing to put in that time and effort
to it then I I mean they like
if you're timid about
your ability to get there then you
either have two options you either start
writing one script and see if you're any
good at it pass it along to people and
get feedback and go from there but that
process of writing a script is going to
take at least two years probably on your
first pass
um and second and it's like you can at
least do that like without moving to Los
Angeles to just to see you know before
you decide to Jump Right In because it's
expensive it's all about networking and
who you know and
um what your last project was and
there's a lot of Egos and all sorts of
things that you have to kind of fight
and I get that that's not for everybody
and frankly it's not for most of us but
it's part of the of the deal
uh so it takes a lot of perseverance to
kind of
keep going and and if you're uh not sure
if you want to do it before you even
begin then I think that that really you
probably shouldn't do it
um and don't waste your time but if you
believe that you really have a knack for
something and you have
uh a vision or a
um a voice
that's unique
then go for it and uh make sure that you
uh you know just plan just plan for it
to be a long road you know like make
sure that that's something you really
willing to invest in because it is a
sacrifice to some extent too but it is
possible at the end of a decade let's
say you know it doesn't have to take
that long of course but
um
but you know like I made my first
film out of film school and then it took
me over 10 years to make another one to
give you some example um I'm not upset
about that I've had so many experiences
as an editor and other jobs that have
have not only been fulfilling but have
led uh to my experience really growing
and allowing to learn from others who
have been doing this for a long time and
that's really invaluable as well so part
of it is like just don't don't expect to
start at the top because there's a lot
of people that have been doing it for a
lot longer than you and there's always
something to learn
great what what about
I don't expect to start at the top but I
want to cut it in half to five years how
can I hack the system how can I game it
if you find out let me know
I mean realistically it's just like you
have to love what you like the the idea
of working on movies not even making
your own in order to do it
if uh if it's only I just want to make
my own stuff then stay far away from Los
Angeles
and get your uh crew together and do it
on your own and then take a uh you know
a crack at the film festivals and see if
you get any attraction
but um that would be my advice anymore I
just think that like trying to cut
corners and things like that it's you
know
I mean if I if I if I had the
the ability to to just cut my my success
in half so I could get there further
faster you know I mean of course we
would all be doing that so I don't know
how to answer that other than
you know
be sure that you want to do this stuff
what advice would you have given to
Thomas Ferretti 15 years ago probably
the same
I mean like I knew that I was in it for
the long haul but uh but I think that's
what's interesting for me is how much
I've
changed since
uh you know like from 15 years ago to
where I'm at now
um
I think that
uh I I think I definitely like like you
know drank the Kool-Aid of like oh yeah
I made a movie and and
um and now I'm ready to make another one
kind of thing and and but but it was
almost like the moment I got to Los
Angeles I was like nope I gotta figure
out how to pay for the rent that I I
just got for this like place and you
know it was also during the recession
like and nobody was paying anything
everything everybody was like getting
three month internships that might hire
you on and and then you'd be lucky if
they did that
so my priority really early on changed
to surviving survival mode kind of stuff
and getting the best jobs I could
so
the advice I'd give myself is stay keep
at it and keep you know uh keep the
determination to to get there which I
did so I I but I think the interesting
thing part the interesting part for me
is how maybe my mindset changed over
time because of the experiences I've had
where I'm less I'm less racing
and I'm more going at my own pace if
anything uh the stamina changes slightly
but that doesn't mean the determination
changes I still want to go where I want
to where like my dreams are still the
same but but how fast I need to get
there has changed let's say between when
I was a kid and where I am now and
um I think that's just because I'm older
I like I've I've have enough experience
to I also have other kind of you know
aspects to my life where my my film was
I mean sorry film uh wasn't the only
thing in everything you know where now I
have you know my dog and my girlfriend
and like I was sort of like I it's just
like natural that you you kind of like I
want to balance my life out a little bit
and I am happy if it takes an extra five
years or ten years for me to
um
get to wherever my end goal is because
in fact I don't even really know what
that is anymore so
um it's it's it's making movies but is
it making the Lord of the Rings I don't
know I would probably love that but uh
but realistically I'm just like kind of
like happy making movies and being
involved in and if I get a shot every
once in a while to like direct a film
that I really believe in then I'm gonna
take that but I also really believe that
I don't need to direct every movie that
I want to make
um
and that's maybe something that's
different than I was when I was 15 where
I was just all about directing and stuff
you know I think the industry itself has
changed me quite a bit but also I find
Value in all these other things too I
think it's cool
so
yeah I guess to wrap it around uh I
would tell myself
um be open to all types of opportunities
except for reality TV
which is what I edit up uh early on I
told myself I wouldn't do that and I'm
glad I I didn't because I saw people get
kind of
um
kind of pigeonholed into that direction
and I did not want to go down that road
just for money